16 year old samish John has been
training as a mechanic at the shop in
Istanbul for a few months three years
ago his parents divorced his mother was
forced to find a job to support him but
when turkey's inflation skyrocketed he
decided to drop out of school
even if you have two people earning
minimum wage salaries life is difficult
for that household I give my salary to
my family I also work as a photographer
over the weekends I spend that money for
myself I did not want to force my family
to send me to school especially as a
Young Man
inflation reached 85 percent when the
government cut interest rates at the end
of 2021. in a year Galera has lost more
than twice its value compared to the US
dollar
s runs his 40 year old Dowry shop he
says he's had to increase prices five
times in the past year
inflation is like a monster increases in
the minimum wage don't help people if we
didn't have Arab tourists it would be
too difficult not only for us all of
Istanbul the hotels groceries and
markets
higher rent water and electricity bills
are weighing heavily on the small
business
there are three people working here I
need one more but I can't afford it many
businesses around here have started to
employ Afghan or Syrian refugees
president
announced a total of 80 increase in the
minimum wage this year on top of the 50
high at the end of last year turkey is
gearing up for an election in mid-2023
president erdogan is expected to pump
more money into the economy before the
vote which is likely to lead to more
price increases he also promised to
reduce inflation to 40 percent in a few
months it is unclear how we will manage
both but in the meantime Turkish
citizens are finding it more and more
difficult to make ends meet
Al Jazeera Istanbul